I really feel we didn't get to go over
this and I feel everyone got too serious
about liver King can we just pull up his
apology and hear the first line where he
says I [__] up
why it's just funny okay it's crazy he
like went on an apology tour yeah
yeah like I wonder if he's just gonna
keep going like just keep
being liver King yeah probably probably
right yeah steroid King sometimes
there's a weird effect when you double
down yeah sometimes there's a weird
thing where
um
when you double down some people just
buy into it just because yeah I don't
know but press play finals I'm making
this video
to apologize
because I [__] up that's all that's
all I wanted to do that's the way he
said it should be in a [__] song dude
that should be it to apologize
because I [__] up because I [__] up
because I [__] up [__] up [__] up
[__] up [__] [__] [__] [__] because I
[__] up I've been watching so funny
because I lied anyway what you've been
watching just like how that's how my
brain is thinking right now because I've
been watching like a ton of tutorials on
how to make house music yeah so this is
like I just think in like drops now yeah
that's good yeah it's good it's really
healthy
just framing things you know throughout
my day is how could I how could I make
oh this would be a sick draw it's sick
the king of England has just died
a second Tesla has hit the second tower
that's not my joke someone else tweeted
that from the fake Tesla account oh man
it's kind of funny how like Elon is just
you won't got his feelings which he got
his feelings yeah I mean dude
do you want me to step down I said yes
on that yeah I did too because it's
funny yeah I know me too I was like you
gotta I got a vote Yes for this just to
see what happens
oh you guys really want me to yeah get
the [__] out
[Laughter]
17 million votes damn bro
and it was a 57 yes hey but he bombed at
that Chappelle so he just can't get it
out of it yeah I didn't watch that hey
man did you watch it I watched the clip
of it just people going
can you pull it up he bombed in the
hardest way dude he ripped a Band-Aid
off yeah he should have tried an open
mic or something first yeah
and was Chappelle like trying to protect
him or something I didn't watch the full
Clips I don't know the full context I
just got little Snippets of just people
being [__] angry and him being on
stage going
oh
I'm gonna do that damn
[Music]
[Applause]
we're expecting this were you
it sounds like some of them people you
fired are in the audience
[Applause]
that's funny yeah what a dystopian thing
is a hyper financially successful
comedian joking to a billionaire about
how
these some people you laid off yeah out
there yeah it's like haha wait no wait
yeah yeah although yeah
I don't know
I don't know I wouldn't try to take this
any deeper than it's funny that people
booed the [__] out of him
yeah I mean it's it's yeah I don't know
people were like like hating on
Chappelle because they're like why would
he even do that why would he bring him
out Bring Out Elon yeah
yeah I don't know there's a part of me
that thinks it's really funny to put a
guy like Elon in front of people that
aren't his crowd yeah oh just to make
him feel uncomfortable just to see what
would happen yeah I think in that
respect uh it was funny yeah I don't
know I just more so like to think this
is elon's version of trying to get back
on stage after uh remember the one we
watched Tesla like whatever yeah yeah
whatever that convention is yeah
he he killed yeah he crushed yeah that
was a good sash yeah went out there
again and ate [__] so now he's on the
internet yeah do you guys like me please
and they don't yeah they don't
it's just funny like everything he's
doing with Twitter it's like the whole
the whole time when he was taking over
is like free speech and like
you know and then now he's just like
like policies are going into place and
then being taken away the same day yeah
and he's Banning journalists and yeah
it's just crazy it's like I've never
seen this amount of like he's just I
don't know it's just like wasn't meant
to be you know
it's so crazy for a CEO of a company to
walk in and be like
do you guys like me yeah yeah
I just feel like so many people warned
them they're like this is gonna suck ass
dude yeah what are you doing don't do
this he's like no no I can make this
right yeah and then three weeks in he's
like I can't I can't do it what will be
the fastest in and out
possibly yeah
has the CEO bombed this hard before I
mean I don't know but like I don't know
from the outside it looks like it's just
tanking yeah he's he's even tweeted like
it's spiraling to bankruptcy and all
this crazy [__]
like did you see Lex Lex Friedman you
know Lex Freeman right yeah yeah he
replied he was like why don't you let
why don't you let me run Twitter for a
little bit sorry what this is a joke
what did you say you're like you know
Alexa yeah that's my guy oh yeah yeah
Texas yeah we chat no he's like
like you know he's like he's like I
don't know if it's a character or what
but he's all about like you know like
hearing people loud and like yeah and
kindness and love which I guess I
appreciate but
I do it's just it just seems like
sometimes he's a little naive too sure
and he's like replies to Elon he's like
why don't you let me run Twitter
and elon's like I mean
yeah this is it right here
you must like pain a lot one catch you
have to invest your life savings in
Twitter and it has been in the fast lane
to bankruptcy since May still want the
job he goes yes we'll turn it around no
you won't dude
no you won't I like how Elon is trying
to Garner some like sympathy there or
something what do you mean you know
you have to like a lot of pain yeah and
you need your life savings in it okay
for it to be fair yeah okay yeah we
didn't tell you to put [__] 80
billion dollars in the [__] you know
the Bird app we didn't tell you to do
that [__] dude the only thing funnier is
someone to voluntarily follow up and be
like I'll do this yeah dude yeah
after watching the train wreck of the
past four weeks I'll do it
I like Lex I think it's just this is
just funny yeah what if yes we will turn
it around dude the odds are stacked
against you let me just tell you that
but what if Twitter becomes
you know and and sorry to frame
everything this way but it's corny but
what if this becomes like that you know
the Apollo of
Tech yeah like you know what if CEO
after CEO just gets up in front of
Twitter they're like I'll fix it and
they're they're all just going like that
everyone's like oh Eat the Rich this and
that it's not policy it's not anything
it's just Twitter yeah yeah they all are
vying to be the one yeah to crush it
yeah and they all go broke and that's
how they all bleed out financially is
just like I'll put my 50 billion up and
then they're like holy [__]
I ate [__] so hard and the person that
comes out on top is drill yeah yeah you
know what I mean he somehow wins yeah at
all yeah